[Music]
dr. bringing them together the
pedophiles like do they deserve empathy
like people who are serial killers
across the board
Hitler he's on there like I can
empathize with Hitler but I don't think
before we go any further 30 seconds to
explain the backstory since 2010 we've
made videos to create a movement for
human good humanizing ex-felons police
officers teen moms sworn enemies around
the world just about the only people we
didn't human eyes was us as we grew
bigger it seemed like some people
thought were some kind of faceless
soulless corporation so a couple weeks
ago we wonder what happen if we actually
put ourselves in front of camera instead
of behind it worried about the C is six
of us who had no clue what they would be
asked so you guys maybe get to know us
just a little bit deeper enjoy
[Music]
I mean we work in media I mean this is
the thing I know there's not like money
that's stashed away that has my name on
it I just there's not enough of it and
you know we all work crazy hours and you
know put ourselves through all kinds of
mental stress to make the content that
we do and we're all making you know like
middle-class money off of it you
actually pay us like more than a lot of
people I know yeah every true media
company I'm saying we pay more than most
big media companies actually which is
surprising the interns are planning a
revolt because we're being underpaid
that's all I have to say when I was
working in like for like film and media
when I was in college I never got paid
for my internet is dying like zero
that's true I just like when we leave
that we paid our yeah I think it's a
good thing
surprise if I'm drunk I'm making a fool
out of like if I'm carrying you out of
the bar when I think I'm drunk I think
of like worse
John possible like I've actually won
like have a great time with everyone in
our company but I also know that if I
got super wasted and everyone was
carrying me out that I would feel really
embarrassed - yeah I'm not 21 yes I just
don't know I think in terms of thought
we're not we're not there yet and that's
sprung from a larger conversation that
we had recently of like we need to check
our biases we all kind of lean a little
bit more left and so in terms of like
thoughts and opinions on things I think
we can be more diverse and we need a
trump voter like you guys were saying I
could probably use a trump voter I can
vote for Trump if you need I actually
think that there are some folks that
lean slightly conservative in our
company but I don't think that folks we
do necessarily good enough job to
protect that space for them actually and
we need some more like more deliberately
conservative people
[Music]
I just think you're like a really cool
dude to be honest and I love having
conversations with you and I appreciate
you spending the time to you know cater
to my stupidity sometimes so what's the
dumbest question he's ever during one of
our interviews David was like I don't
understand why you guys have leadership
meetings and I feel like I should be
part of those leadership meetings and it
was like an interview for this
internship Wow like I totally admire
this like he's just curious I wanted to
know
yeah Jason's the kind of guy who like
you bring him a hot fudge sundae and
then he's gonna be like oh wait where's
the cherry like we're not just gonna do
a video about a couple like we're gonna
do a video where like they reveal really
personal information and they cry and
they're really photogenic and they're
epic it's under six minutes long growing
up I would like come home with a s and
my dad to be like like nothing just know
like but if you get a B you're like oh
something is going wrong and I'm like
man what kind of dad do I want to be
like what kind of boss so I want to be a
that's not the kind of boss I want to be
and the reason I'm standing here is
because I feel sometimes frustrated
myself because I'm like I know that our
expectations for you guys are really
really high and I think that one thing I
don't do well enough is like just say
hey you did like a great job like hey I
see the effort you're doing a fantastic
job I'm kind of like yeah you should be
doing a good job which I don't think is
like it's not good
let me try to do that better so it's
something I'm like I'm still trying to
grow into a little bit
[Laughter]
this is a really tough one for me
John something we always talk about are
like not to bring it up again the
pedophiles like do they deserve empathy
like people who are serial killers like
to stand here and sit here and listen to
a pedophile explain why he became one I
feel like that's almost a gateway of
saying it's acceptable what you did like
empathy is not forgiveness it's not
approval but it is an openness to try
and understand why they do what I do I'm
gonna move and I just think that's
essential to like solving problems I
think just being open to understanding
every human that has ever existed it's
just like essential to being like
creating progress I think all of us are
actually capable of like tremendous evil
or tremendous good but I do think that
by us like acknowledging the evil that's
within us or even like our selfishness
it allows us to be more honest with hey
but I want to fight for a good for me
that's almost like yes we do give them
empathy but it's not like they deserve
empathy because we need to understand
them but yeah but I guess I would say
it's a human right like it's a
fundamental human right to receive
empathy across the board
Hitler he's on there yeah like I just
think it's fundamental yeah I think I
can empathize sure I can empathize with
Hitler but I don't think I don't think
he deserves okay I just I feel like
there's a difference there right for me
at least
[Music]
three-two-one
there are so many people in the world
who thinks so differently from each
other and my job is to make sure that
those voices are represented I'm doing
it all emotional I want to make more of
an impact I don't think I'm very good
night job sorry I just I I need to be
better I need to try harder I need to do
a lot more because it's like there's so
much we could do there's so many people
who aren't being heard and like we were
like we're here we can resurrect that
and sorry I'm not making any sense you
care so much and that's why I believe
you're doing a good job I don't know if
anyone comes myself included into the
role that we have ready to do what we're
gonna do but what makes us special and
what makes you special is that you are
like battling so hard and you feel like
you're not improving but like I see your
growth and mainly because you care so
much about doing a good job and like
that's gonna totally pay off so I think
we are making an impact I don't think
we're curing cancer
but you know you know our audience is
constantly engaging with us even when
it's like on the negative side even when
we're getting hate that's just at least
like stimulating and that's it's real I
mean you guys know our vision is that we
want to create a movement of
changemakers for human good and I think
in a lot of ways the success of jewbilee
will not be visible for another like a
decade or two decades but I really
believe then like 20 years from now
there could be someone or a group of
people who are like I did what I did I
cured cancer because like a long time
ago I saw this video or as part of like
this movement there really instilled in
me this idea of empathy and
courage I don't know I mean I don't
necessarily go into this thinking that
we're gonna change the world but I do go
into it thinking that we're contributing
a lot of good right now we're like in a
state of a world that I think we are so
divided that even like having a simple
dialogue conversation in some small way
is like changing the world so yeah like
when I talk about our vision that's like
a hundred year or like a third year
vision and what does that look like
right now it literally is like let me
just agree or listen to someone that I
completely disagree with but let me be
clear like our goal is actually still to
get to the moon but right now we're like
trying to figure out how to put this
bolt on this screw you know Cheerios
yeah well why not why not us right like
why shouldn't we be the ones that
created this great movement and I don't
know I believe in you guys so much like
I believe in what we've built so much
that I believe we can be the ones to do
it and I think that people see that and
hopefully they see hopefully they'll
resonate thanks for watching that you
guys this was kind of an unusual episode
we you know want to live by what we
champion and a lot of times we put our
cast on the hot seat so we're like we
should probably do the same thing to
ourselves
just for fun yeah if you guys want to
engage in more of a content let us know
what you think in the comments below for
future episodes but also follow us on
Instagram that's where we actually
collected a lot of the props we'll see
you next time
all right peace up